the Joe Rogan experienced well Biden's a
weird guy do you see all this videos him
sniffing those kids no what is that
about it could just be a sweet old
grandpa but no some sweet Oh grandpa's
don't want to [ __ ] kids they do do that
I the thing is it would in a sense be
make more sense to people if he was just
like handsy right it's like okay this is
like I don't even know where to put this
like where do you put sniffing yeah it's
a [ __ ] weird thing he's just a weird
guy did you know about the the
plagiarism from back when he ran three
times yeah I think he's [ __ ] in the
primary because his track record is
pathetic so the first time he ran was an
88 cycle right he announces in July he
has to fold by September because this
plagiarism scandal right he runs again
in a way it comes in like what sixth in
Iowa has to pull so he in terms of his
history of running for presidency it's
been very very poor he's a good backup
man he's right right because he's a
steady reliable result yes you stay the
[ __ ] out this look it's they're gonna
eat him alive that's ugly it's gonna be
ugly you're gonna hate it bro and you're
not gonna win they're gonna don't think
he's gonna but he's the front-runner you
look at the Democratic polls in terms of
the Democrats you know who is the
front-runner at this point in 2003 Oh
Joe Lieberman because he was the vice
president of Canada from Gore yeah
everyone knew his name what happened
with that guy he lost it he where'd he
go he what he went right didn't he he
what they he lost the primary in his
state of Connecticut then he ran as an
independent Democrat won again by
reelected he killed universal health
care because they needed 60 votes and
he's like [ __ ] you we're not doing it so
they had to have this Obamacare market
system because of him and now everyone
hates him didn't he turn into a
Republican though no no but he endorsed
that heard you became a Nazi
[Laughter]
Joe Lieberman invents a peer or that
your Nazis the new right yeah the fact
that he gets called one that's the funny
[ __ ] ever
while he's wearing a yarmulke people
common or not so that you you'd never
suspect it yeah sneaky it's a we're
sneaky hmm